in general would you advise other
filmmakers or actors to make sure to
attend their festival yeah if you're in
a festival and you don't go you missing
an opportunity you've put it on a credit
card and go beg a room to stay with a
friend put it out on Craigslist do
whatever you have to go to be there to
be associated with your film it's a
golden opportunity these film festivals
are you know you work you work work so
so hard on a film and you've got in
front of an audience and there's press
there for you not to be there's it's
it's a real big opportunity missed if
you can go in anyway go and once you go
what are you bringing with you aside a
great suit maybe your your cards what
are you doing so that you're not that
guy that's you know totally promoting
themselves but at the same time you're
available you're approachable you're
asking other people about their work
everybody that you meet everybody has
work they're doing that they want to
promote everybody has something they
want to tell you don't talk about
yourself talk about them hi I'm Bill /
junior that's all you have to say to
somebody in the industry hi I'm Bob
Jones they will tell you then everything
they want you listen you nod you ask
intelligent follow-up questions and they
will say Wow
he's one of the best conversationalist
ever that's because you talked about
them and you listen to them everybody
wants to be listened to
so never start sentences with I in other
words if you're at the film festival
they don't need to know what else you've
been well yes I just did this web series
and I'm working on blah blah blah and I
went to producers callback you already
had the Film Festival you're in the
freaking movie that's running at the
Film Festival now let it be about them
and that makes you appear even bigger
because if you're with a big star I
don't think that you're ever going to
hear them say you know oh I just
finished this movie with Scorsese they
don't need to say that and so that's the
kind of R that you want to put off is
that you're about other people telling
all my tricks here
you